do you ever think about that like is
there going to be some fundamental
Tipping Point here where we understand
things that we didn't ever think we
could understand and what those things
might be well I you know my I mean I
love these conversations so my father
was a particle
physicist um and we used to talk about
the intersection all the time of of
physics and biology like at some point
as you understand subatomic particles
and understand prediction like at what
point could you really understand all
cell your function and predict outcomes
the thing that I love about science and
I always try to get kids to think about
is like there's just an endless amount
of open questions and for us to ponder
like there is like where it's all
connected in some way you know the world
of physics and what my dad was studying
and know the search of mass and
neutrinos and you know again we just had
this Memorial and I was with a couple
friends like talking about the neutrino
world and like they're all over but they
don't interact with any of ourselves
they don't interact with the Earth like
they don't like like what but how is
that connected yeah what is the purpose
what is the purpose and why is my dad
his life what is it doing out there yeah
right but I think that there is going to
be a world where at some point you will
be able to understand the very Basics
and the foundations of you know how how
the world the universe really is working
and then how that actually led to all of
us um I think that's going to be far off
but I do think that there's a lot of
really phenomenal discoveries happening
in very Basics whether it's in physics
and in chemistry um and then I think
also that brings in the whole world of
large language models and the ability
for you to predict things now like
protein function and for you to predict
you know variant resolution so
understanding what a particular mutation
is doing like that
you know that's going to be that's
that's going to be the fascinating world
and I think understanding the one thing
that I always have a huge appreciation
for is just how complex the human body
is and so your ability to predict all
those different interactions in your
body and exactly how that's turned into
you is is just like such an exciting and
interesting problem what have we learned
in terms of healthcare let's get back to
this pursuit of of hitting 100 years old
or 120 we we seem to have in terms of
Span in the Western
World um the things that kill us seem to
be self-inflicted diabetes you know
smoking opioid suicide it's almost like
where're the the the limitation now has
been the the Surplus and and the
abundance we have in society in the West
is kind of like capped us out at
whatever it is 76 or 77 year old average
lifespan but you do see people who have
access to healthcare and some of these
new technologies and maybe some
thoughtfulness really starting to live
to 90 100 but also as pedia what is his
name AA sort of talks about health span
and I think that might be the big unlock
is that like hey 80s and 90s you could
actually be like Charlie Munger and
doing q&as with you know world's
smartest people asking you really
challenging questions and be witty and
and be there and not like be a vegetable
so what have we
learned uh from this or have you learned
in the company from the last 17 18 years
14 15 million people doing this that
applies most traumatically to health
span lifespan and just living a better
life like what's what's been
accomplished here well I think the first
thing that's really um almost the lowest
hanging fruit is you have certain
genetic variants like brocha mutation or
Lynch syndrome which are sort of well
known so brocha mutations can make you
highrisk for breast cancer and a number
of other cancers lych syndrome can make
you high risk for early colon cancer and
other conditions what always saddens me
is that genetic testing despite being a
20-year-old technology and despite being
very affordable is not a universal part
of any health care system and it really
should be and there's all kinds of
really important genetic variants that
every single person should know about
today so for example all your cancer
risks if if you have a brocca
mutation you should know about it
because you can be proactive about doing
a masectomy or about screening for
cancer and if you Lynch syndrome you
should be proactive then about
colonoscopies um if you're high risk for
something called Factor five and that
means for blood clotting you should be
proactive about how you are flying and
make sure that you're wearing
compression stockings or moving around
when you're on an airplane I can go
through a whole list of genetic variants
that are important for people and their
outcomes and so the easiest thing for
right now when I think about people
increasing their health span is about
avoiding preventable
deaths and so right now there's a lot of
people who have a condition where they
could really manage it and they are not
getting access to that genetic
information through the existing Health
Care system and largely in part because
I think it's just it's not part of
reimbursement system it's not part of
the education system but through 23 me
and through other groups out there you
have access to it people should get
access to it now and I think you're
going to be able to prevent a big number
of preventable deaths I think then you
do have a lot of conditions like heart
disease obesity Etc that have an
environmental component as well but
there are genetics with that so
understanding the genetic components
there I think it will help people be
able to also manage that manage their
lifestyle understand for instance like
with all these glp ones now who is it
who actually really should be proactive
thinking about that before they end up
having any other sort of serious health
consequences from obesity like how do
you actually help use those those
therapies and get it to people at the
right time it's super fascinating when I
hear you talk about how obvious this is
it reminds me I don't know if you've
ever read about like um the the
introduction of the seat belt uh you
know and the shoulder belt and like
airbags like we had these things so many
years earlier than we actually
implemented them and it's like we have
people driving around in cars and we
could easily put an airbag and a
shoulder belt in them and save 100,000
lives a year whatever it is and oh by
the way it cost $99 or $199 whatever it
costs and we're not doing it as a
society is there any society out there
that's you know I don't know smaller
affluent Nordic country that just said
you know what everybody in the country
is going to have this as a uh offering
for free as part of their universal
healthcare has anybody made that jump
yet Canada Norway I don't know I think
the closest is actually in the UK the UK
has a couple initiatives they have the
UK bio bank and they have um a new
initiative called the um um um the our
future health and that you know UK
biobank has half a million people and
our future health is five million people
and so they talk about returning those
results to individuals um the US has an
initiative as well um to get a million
people but they have not returned
results yet um I think there's a couple
things like I think one like the Health
Care system is not well set up to fund
prevention and I think a lot of
Physicians are also not trained on how
to use genetic information so if you
think about if I if I find out that
you're higher risk for something um you
know how is it you know all those costs
you know for instance let's say you're
higher risk for colon colon cancer and
I'm going to go and do proactive
colonoscopies on you um you know the the
way the Health Care system works as
they're going to look at what does that
cost of
preventing versus just treating you once
you have the
disease okay I got a funny story to tell
you house of macademia is graciously
sponsored the all-in summit and to wow
the crowds they created a special
edition salt and vinegar pack of
macadamia notes and guess what people
went crazy for them dozens have been
messaging the founder Brandon
asking him to make the salt and vinegar
nuts available on the website listen
you've heard me rave about the health
benefits of macadamias but don't take it
from me the most health conscious people
in the world are eating them Dr Andrew
huberman I like his podcast I started
listening to it he mentioned he's s some
academias in his GQ profile and that guy
Brian Johnson he was on the podcast when
he wasn't a health lunatic he's trying
to verse his aging and he eats Macadamia
so all you really need to know House of
macademia products are delicious and
they support good health my favorite dry
roasted chocolate dip Macadamia you know
I get my chocolate dipped in there and
they also have a dipped snack bar so I
put a couple of those in my backpack I
put a couple of them in my little roller
so I have a healthy and delicious snack
I make a better decision listen if I had
a candy bar which you know like
sometimes they break down and I buy one
of those not a good choice for me now I
make a better choice House of macadamia
they got a new product Macadamia milk
get a free month supply of macadamia
milk with any order at House of
macadamia m.com twist that's a free
month supply of macademia milk with the
code
twist2 House of macadamias